we lived on the third floor of a block
of flats and when the nazi party
came around collecting all the jews
my aunt who stayed with us looked out
and saw what was going on she couldn't
do anything about my mother who by that
time was taken downstairs into the
courtyard where they gathered all the
jewish women
[Music]
why do you think the jewish people were
singled out for persecution
it's really very difficult to understand
even now
what made the germans the nazi party and
hitler in particular
zero in on the jews hitler of course was
an animal he felt that the jews were not
up to the standards of the german people
and he felt that the jews had to be
eliminated in order to create higher
society a better society
it's 1941 when it all started i was four
years old and from then on
life never really
became
anything like normal
and i had to go through various stages
and as a young boy i don't think i
really understood what was going on
around me however i do think that it
must have affected me
we lived on the third floor of a block
of flats and when the nazi party
came around collecting all the jews
all the jewish women because by that
time the jewish men were taken away
they went from flat to flat it's a
five-story block and they went from flat
to flat so my aunt who stayed with us
looked out and saw what was going on she
couldn't do anything about my mother who
by that time was taken downstairs into
the courtyard where they gathered all
the jewish women and she suddenly
remembered that on the same floor there
was a
family or at least a man whom we knew
and who were friends non-jewish and he
took a hell of a lot of a chance and
said
john let's go she grabbed me
and rushed me across to this flat just
around the corridor
and begged this man
to hide us and of course it could have
gone either way he could have said i'm
sorry what the hell do you expect me to
do i don't want to go to prison or get
killed
but no he has taken a chance a huge
chance he took us in he
closed he took us he closed the main
door took us into a cupboard
shot us into the cupboard said shut up
don't say anything keep quiet
see what we can do
unfortunately
the nazi party representatives didn't go
into his fled because he was non-jewish
they knew that because they knew
everybody who lived in those places
amazing the research they have done
and so
we stayed in this cupboard i don't know
how long maybe an hour
it felt much more it felt like a
lifetime you can imagine how i must have
felt disorientated frightened
not really understanding what was going
on
while my mother was taken away
the ghetto is a huge area it was just
behind the hangar the budapest synagogue
which is the second largest in the world
after the one in new york
and the choice was if you don't stay in
the ghetto then you go to a
concentration camp or you get you get
shot as i said they were cramming us in
as much as possible it didn't matter
whether it was comfortable or not
it was a very strange way of
keeping
jews together without
able to do anything you couldn't there
was no radios no telephones no
entertainment no nothing all you could
do is talk to the 20 people around you
but you couldn't go out
because if you went out you never know
what happened to you you could have been
killed or you could have caught the
disease this entry typhus
typhoid was one of the
biggest problem
there's no medication there was food was
nothing
you survived on hardly anything so the
situation was dying
how long were you in the ghetto for
oh it was several months
some people stayed there longer we
stayed there for about three or four
months
and
if you imagine we did not know that the
ghetto was mined
ready to be
exploded by the germans so that all of
us in the 290 building
would be blown up and die
fortunately for us unfortunately for the
germans they did not have time because
they had to retreat so fast because of
the soviet army coming in so quickly
that they didn't have time to
blow us up so if you like we were very
lucky
when the russians came in everybody
thought this is wonderful we have we
have freedom at last but of course the
russians are simply there to annex
hungary as a satellite country to be
part of the soviet empire and that was
their aim and that's what they achieved
and that's why
they would not tolerate any opposition
we realize sooner or later
that this is a life which any
young intelligent student or indeed
adult could not live with
the spies were everywhere neighbors were
spying on neighbors
you no freedom of the press you have no
freedom of talking
no freedom of the newspapers no freedom
on the radio so you were living in an
occupied country effectively
and now moving ahead to the uprising in
parliament square would you be able to
expand a little bit on your memories of
that our flat
was
five minutes walk away from parliament
square
and
we found out from friends that there
will be this demonstration and i said
okay well
two or three of us said let's go and see
what this is about
maybe this is going to be a new life
starting so we just walk around the
corner effectively which is surrounded
by big buildings and the houses of
parliament it's a big square as i said
there's 20 000 i counted how many people
i said 200 000 people were at the square
and the whole idea was that this was
orchestrated by the students but not
only the students asking for a new
regime for the new government for the
new prime minister to make life better
for the hungarian citizens
obviously nobody realized that
none of this can possibly happen under a
strict soviet regime even though the
soviets retreated
making us feel as if we have freedom but
in fact what happened was that they
surrounded the square with tanks they
were stationed on the tops of blocks of
flats
and they were just waiting for the
signal and
when
i don't know why i said to my friends
right we have been here we've seen it
i'm not really feeling comfortable
let's go and we walked back home and
when we arrived in our flat we could
hear the gunshots
so i was very lucky
to survive
as far as i know
around 300 people
were gunned down
that different reports uh different
people have different stories
it doesn't matter how many people
whether 300 400
it was a massacre and that way the
soviets proved that they mean business
and nobody is going to stand up against
them
can you imagine the next day i went down
and saw the blood and the clothes
on on the square which wasn't cleared at
that stage
it's not a very pleasant sight
if you think about it this is the second
time i have been very lucky the first
time when the ghetto wasn't
blown up and now the second time when i
for some reason didn't stay in the
square
what made you decide to escape hungary a
friend of mine with whom we eventually
escaped
sat down and we said look
is this life going to
be what we want or is it worth taking a
chance
whatever that chance is
and try to escape
now you couldn't just take a luggage
with you or
a
case because
the bridges were manned by army or
police and if they see you
carrying anything like that say what are
you doing where are you going and that's
all you need to be
immediately imprisoned so
that's why all i could take with me was
a bag of food and my teddy
and simply lock the gate lock the
door of the flat
and forget that i live there and leave
everything behind so we went over the
bridge in the afternoon just
walking across and stayed with a friend
at a friend's house
a flat near the railway station so that
we could start our journey
seven o'clock in the morning
it was interesting because the train we
took
went towards austria now i had tickets
because i worked on the railway as did
my friend so we were able to present the
genuine
ticket
to go on this journey
and
we found out that the train stops about
10 kilometers or so before the border
and that was the stop we got off and
then we found that there were many many
other hungarians doing the same
we were frightened because we knew
that where we had to go was mined
there were tanks going around nearby
there were searchlights
watching what's going on
and
we had a vague idea of where we are
going but by that time it must have been
about 15 of us or so
trying to escape uh towards the border
and then we suddenly found ourselves
under a watchtower
now if that watchtower would have been
manned we would have been shot
and that was the third time that i was
luckier we were lucky that watch star
for some reason
wasn't manned
and there was a bridge immediately under
the watchtower
which is in fact at the village called
andao and that's where we crossed over
where the austrians waited for us and
welcomed us
when you were greeted by the austrians
were you suspicious or were you
immediately met with relief
absolutely no question of being
suspicious this was a huge relief
we knew that freedom is there waiting
for us we knew that we are in good hands
we knew that at last we have a chance to
understand what freedom or life is
really
what really is about and i think
as soon as we
got across the austrian border
we knew that we are safe and
the relief was enormous
in vienna
we were looked after by the red cross
they gave us a daily uh
amount very small amount just to live
with
they allowed us to wander around and
nobody knew what happens next
and
the rumor was that each embassy offered
permits
to go to their country
uh the limited number of permits and the
question then was where do we go
and
many people said oh well go to australia
it's wonderful
or south africa
and then we said well do we really want
to go that far away
i think europe is where i want to stay
i don't think i want to do that
would i want to go to a
non-english-speaking country and the
answer was again no i've already spoken
i already learned a little bit of
english so
i would have to stay
in a country where english is spoken so
that really meant that england was the
right answer
do you have any ideas about what allows
people to treat other people in such
terrible ways
well it's all
the same really isn't it whether it was
the nazis whether it's the chinese
whether it's what's happening in asia or
what what the russians are doing for
example it's all uh politics it's all
grabbing power
and there will always be people like
that and there will always be situations
which are just repeating history repeats
itself and unfortunately there's very
little
one can do other than try to educate and
this education is the word which i would
use when i talk to schools i am very
lucky to be here to talk to you
and i just hope that this is just one
step in the right direction
[Music]
there was a witch doctor who had laid
this child down
put herbs all around her body and was
about to cut her
before
the security guard
found her and rescued her and brought
her to this
baby's home where i was working